المسايره التي اثارت كل هذا الجدل تعتبر
العمود الفقري لاسطول الاستطلاع الجوي
للجيش الامريكي وهي طائره استطلاع مسيره
من نوع ريبر ام كيو 9 تستخدمها القوات
الجويه الامريكيه لجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه واجراء مهام المراقبه
والبحث والانقاذ والضربات الدقيقه على
اهداف عاليه القيمه وحساسه يبلغ طول ريبر
ام كيو 9 11 مترا وطول جناحيها يبلغ 20
مترا وتحتوي على اجهزه استشعار وكاميرات
تعمل بالاشعه تحت الحمراء وجهاز يعمل
بالليزر لتحديد الاهداف وتعاقدت القوات
الجويه الامريكيه مع شركه جنرال اوتوميكس
لصناعه اكثر من 360 طائره ريبر منذ بدء
البرنامج في عام 2007 وتبلغ تكلفه طائره
حوالي 30 مليون دولار
590 لترا من الوقود لهذه الطائره تسمح لها
التحليق لمسافه
1850 كيلومترا وطيران على ارتفاع يصل الى
اكثر من 15 كيلو مترا كما يمكنها حمل
ثمانيه صواريخ موجهه بالليزر و16 صاروخا
من طراز هالفاير التقارير تقول ان هذه
الطائرات قامت بمهام فوق العراق
وافغانستان وسوريا ودول اخرى ويتم تشغيلها
عن بعد بواسطه فريقين من قاعدتين احدهما
يقود المهمه ويتحكم في الطائره المسيره
بينما يشغل الاخر اجهزه الاستشعار
ويوجه الاسلحه